[Music]
you're celebrating 10 years of marriage
in september what does that mean to you
i'm
paired up with my best friend you know
when that happens you you recognize how
unbelievably lucky you are yep ten years
of marriage and three kids later ryan
really is a lucky guy lucky blake let
him keep the fifth tier welsh football
club he and buddy rob mcelhany bought on
a whim in 2020. how did you explain this
to your wife i'm not that dumb kevin i i
promise you i would consult my wife
before putting pants on um you know
she's the smartest person i know but you
know it's funny that she's actually more
obsessed with wrexham than i am really
yeah i remember we were laying in bed
after we lay in bed together uh we were
laying head after the wembley match and
she's like i'm now as obsessed if not
more than you are with this club and
this community and this town and
everything it represents and where it
can go and she's as obsessed as i am
she's already like looking at the
schedule throughout the year wondering
which matches she can attend
so it's pretty great now the guys who
have no football experience are living
out their ted lasso dreams with a new
docu-series about their underdog team
welcome to wrexham debuts august 24th on
fx the series follows the third oldest
football club in the world as the new
owners try to turn things around and
buck some traditions in the process how
has that gone with folks looking at you
and we're like these clowns are messing
with our tradition hmm yeah well we
recognized that that was going to be a
part of it and the only thing that we
could do is just continue to be as
honest as possible and wear our our
hearts on our sleeves and and where we
mess up we we take responsibility for
but we always make sure that we we go
into every decision um recognizing that
this is something that we have to hold
sacred what was the connection between
you and wrexham football club we had no
direct connection it was just a feeling
what me and my dad thought was because
wrexham's red
deadpool's red though that's the real
reason i'm sorry
you brought a tick-tock and it's cool to
tick-tock on the jerseys but you had to
get rid of your initial sponsor it was
um the horse trailer company
before williams we definitely didn't get
rid of them for all your trailering
needs no we didn't get rid of them
they're on our shorts yeah are there
other traditions that you've had to do
away with where people are like guys
come on rob wanted to get rid of grass
and change it to sand paper look if we
just make the whole pitch sandpaper i
feel like that gives us a competitive
advantage as long as we're practicing
you're not going to see a lot of fake
falls that's for sure
now that you are soccer team owners
football team owners has this inspired
you to coach your kids
my kids want nothing to do with me and
my opinions
as far as any athletic endeavors go and
i don't blame them i i
i think that they are they don't really
trust any of my opinions on really
anything the motivational speeches that
i give my children are wholesale
inappropriate they play soccer they love
it you know but like i'm like let's
quench our thirst on the blood of your
enemies
and they're like dad like dad let's take
it down 55 notches all right
[Music]
you